you know this money thing is very
interesting you guys it's very
interesting because very few things are
what they seem as you get older and
uglier like me and my ears continue to
grow as other well as other parts of my
body continuing to grow my wife says my
belly is continuing to grow and she's
right as I as I do that I am more and
more amazed at how dumb I was and how I
really didn't understand that very few
people who look like they have money
actually do the huge car expensive car
the vastly expensive purse the vastly
expensive vacation on Instagram the
vastly expensive fill-in-the-blank are
very seldom actual indicators of wealth
particularly the first level of wealth
and I would call the first level of
wealth your your first - your first 10
million dollars if you have a net worth
of 1 to 10 million dollars the average
person in that category is not average
to start with they're way above average
but the typical person I guess it should
say typical family that is a one to ten
million dollar net worth is very
understated they buy their clothes at
unimpressive places and they're
unimpressive clothes I they enjoy nice
vacations but they seldom post them for
you to see on Instagram because they
didn't not didn't take you on vacation
they wanted to go on vacation the
Christmas presents around the tree are
very reasonable the car that they drive
is understated and the valet is seldom
impressed until he gets the tip
it's usually a used Camry or nice used
Honda nice old pickup truck of some kind
because the people that achieve that
first layer of wealth that one to ten
million dollars the way they did it is
they didn't do it for you they're not
mad at you but they don't care what you
think they were not living their life to
impress others they loved their life not
yours they were not trying to emulate or
be the Joneses they just didn't care
what you thought there's a real thing
that says when you quit worrying about
what people think and you're actually
living life for you and your family and
that causes you to make completely
different purchases and live a
completely different lifestyle one of
the greatest compliments I had was I had
a very important gentleman who was a
top-level corporate executive with one
of the major companies in our area come
to visit us one night in our home and he
said I was interested to meet you
he said I've been checking you out I've
been asking around town around Nashville
about Dave Ramsey and he said you know
what I always hear I'm interested to
hear that that'll be interesting know
what that you're unassuming hmm it's
kind of a nice compliment it's another
way of saying I don't really do stuff
for what you think I get to do a lot of
nice things but I'm really not doing any
of them for you I don't mean that in a
mean way I'm just you know I didn't buy
the house I live in for you I bought it
for me
and I don't care what you think about it
one way or the other the same with my
boat or my car or my vacation or
whatever and I my net worth these days
is well in excess of the 10 million
dollar level so I'm starting to enjoy
some things at a different level and the
people that I know that are in the
hundred
in dollar $200,000,000 now they do have
some things that are flashy and that
they that are not unassuming that they
do because they can afford it it's a
very small percentage of their world
I've got a friend who's worth about two
hundred million dollars he bought his
wife is five thousand dollar coach purse
which my brain from any i tennessee i
couldnt even get my head around the idea
of doing that until i did it for my wife
later but but a blew my mind that
somebody would pay that for a purse i
still don't understand it but it's just
as wi sharon wants it so but you know
the thing I realized it's an uber who
should they ever spend that on our purse
well nobody should probably but the
truth is it's such a small percentage of
that guy's world he's got a hundred
million two hundred million dollars five
thousand dollars didn't spit it's not
even you know you know it's not like you
it's like you bought a biscuit right
doesn't even come up
and so it's ratios at that point but
what my point is is the first level of
wealth not the guy with a hundred
million or two hundred million of the
gal with it's a billionaire or something
like that that's a different world and
you know that that's that's a different
kind of spending and a different kind of
lifestyle because when they buy a jet
it's a smaller percentage of their world
than it is then when you know most
people buy a car right and so it's a
really different world at that point but
the one to ten million that first layer
of wealth are typically people that if
you walk past him in Walmart you'd have
no idea we were walking out of a church
that I was speaking in in Orlando
Florida the other day and I walked past
this guy tall and slender gray hair I'm
guessing 65 years old blue jeans that
are pressed with a crease down the
middle
really nice cowboy boots and a big Texas
belt on and a pressed shirt I mean he
looked like a million dollars
he's wearing blue jeans and cowboy boots
but I walked past him I told one of my
guys I said that's everyday millionaire
I can spot him now cuz he looks like
just a guy with some jeans and boots on
him but they were very nice and it was
clean and pressed and you know he took
care of himself obviously he was he'd
had a haircut you know he razor had met
his face you know all that kind of stuff
and so that kind of thing is just you
know but you could tell even though
there was nothing flashy he was just
still put together you could feel I can
feel him I can feel the everyday
millionaires now not all of them but
I've just met so many of them over the
decades of doing this and working with
you so my point is my friend Tom Stanley
who wrote the book million or next door
wrote another book later called stop
acting rich that's a great thing to do
act your freakin wage act your wage stop
buying stuff you can't afford with money
you don't have to impress people you
don't even really like it's a signal
you're stupid it's not a signal you're
rich the signal that you're starting to
be rich is that you didn't do any of
that that's my point this is the Dave
Ramsey chef